Traduttore: Lucia Girotti
Revisore: Silvia R.
La mia storia di stasera, pur parlando
del presente, del futuro prossimo,
deve partire dal passato.
Ci sono due storici francesi che negli
anni Ottanta dello scorso secolo
hanno identificato un nuovo modo
di raccontare e di analizzare la storia.
Loro non erano interessati
alla storia dei grandi eventi,
delle battaglie,
dei regnanti, delle leggi;
erano interessati
alla storia di tutti i giorni,
dei desideri delle persone, delle
loro curiosità, delle lettere d'amore,
delle liste della spesa.
Questo mi ha ricordato qualcosa.
Non so se a voi fa venire in mente
la stessa cosa che a me,
però oggi sui social network vediamo
quello che forse cercavano Ariès e Duby
nella vita del Medioevo.
Ci un sacco di persone che vogliono
condividere un sacco di informazioni
su piccoli elementi
della loro storia personale,
e io non sono un paranoico
dei social network,
non penso che stiano peggiorando il modo
in cui interagiamo con le altre persone,
penso forse che c'è una generazione
di ragazzi che ha conosciuto internet
e pensa che internet sia un grande sito,
o due, tre grandi siti,
e non sia invece una sterminata
e meravigliosa città da percorrere.
Questo concetto peraltro è stato definito
da alcuni quello dei giardini chiusi,
dei walled garden.
Il mio talk mira ad analizzare
il modo in cui il Web 2.0 ha cambiato,
in un certo senso, il modo in cui
percepiamo la nostra identità online,
sta cambiando
la nostra percezione della proprietà
e anche,
sotto un certo aspetto,
quanto questo approccio
non sia necessariamente scalabile.
Alcuni di voi si ricorderanno che
nell'aprile 2012 Facebook comprò Instagram
per più di un miliardo di dollari.
In quei giorni,
un'altra azienda famosissima
legata al mondo della fotografia,
Kodak, chiudeva i battenti.
All'epoca Instagram
aveva 19 dipendenti,
Kodak aveva più di 140 000
persone che lavoravano.
Il rapporto di me cliente
nei confronti di Kodak è molto semplice:
io compro da te una pellicola,
su cui imprimerò un mio ricordo,
una foto a cui io tengo particolarmente,
quella foto rimarrà a me.
Nei confronti di Instagram
è un pochino più malizioso, il rapporto,
perché io ricevo da te un dispositivo,
una modalità gratuita
per scattare una foto
che sarà di tua proprietà
e lo faccio gratuitamente
perché il prodotto sono io.
Questo è bene tenerlo a mente.
Prima avete sentito una interessantissima
presentazione sul machine learning,
sulle intelligenze artificiali,
Facebook possiamo sostituirlo
con Google e con altri colossi del web,
stanno costruendo oggi delle
intelligenze artificiali in grado
di analizzare il miliardo e 700.000
persone iscritte a questo social network,
per capirci meglio.
Quello che mi dispiace è che tutta questa
analisi, questa potenza computazionale
viene utilizzata per profilarci
da un punto di vista commerciale.
Secondo me sarebbe molto interessante
sfruttare queste informazioni
e renderle utilizzabili da noi stessi
per conoscerci meglio.
Non è detto
che il miglior psicologo di noi stessi
non debba essere
un'intelligenza artificiale.
Se Internet fosse una città,
il modo in cui è cresciuto il web
negli ultimi anni,
farebbe sì che grandi stazioni della
metropolitana, nella foto alle mie spalle,
o grandi piazze sarebbero questi
grandissimi siti web
che tengono buona parte
del web sui loro server.
Questo concetto è promosso e retto
dal concetto di cloud, di nuvola.
Io credo che tutti noi
abbiamo sentito
in tutte le salse
utilizzare questa parola,
il cloud,
che evoca un'immagine molto bella.
Vediamo questa immagine leggera,
molto grande,
che sta sopra di noi, veglia su di noi.
La realtà, nei fatti, è che il cloud
in realtà sono dei tubi che passano
sotto terra, sotto il mare, tubi
molto grandi e molto vulnerabili,
sono messi sotto terra quindi una piccola
scossa tellurica può interrompere
o influire sulle comunicazioni,
e ci permettono
di mettere in comunicazione
un computer con un altro computer,
con computer molto più grandi.
Avrete capito anche voi
quello che sto per dirvi,
e cioè che non esiste il cloud,
esiste il computer di qualcun altro.
Questo è uno sticker molto simpatico
che ho trovato online,
che ho visto sul computer di un mio amico,
e ritengo che questo
sia profondamente vero.
Tutto funziona perfettamente,
non saremo noi a cambiare il modo
in cui Google, Facebook,
Amazon e i colossi del web
hanno strutturato servizi
che, appunto, incontrano
centinaia di milioni, se non addirittura,
nel caso di Facebook, miliardi di persone,
tutto fin quando
non si arriva al discorso della casa.
Perchè adesso, chissà,
magari alcuni di voi ce l'hanno già,
c'è una crescita, un boom
di elettrodomestici e dispositivi
legati al mondo domestico,
che usano il termine 'domotica',
ma non sempre,
anche in vari altri ambiti della casa,
permetteranno di ottimizzare
una serie di processi.
Quindi immaginiamoci nella nostra mente
un Amazon o un produttore di frigoriferi,
per esempio, che ci regali il frigorifero
a patto che però di farci lui la spesa
e magari conosca quello che io voglio
mangiare oggi perchè è stato condiviso
l'altro giorno su Facebook, oppure
in qualche altro social network.
E vedi di non mangiarne troppo perché
la tua bilancia connessa mi ha detto
che lo scorso weekend al ristorante cinese
hai mangiato un po' troppo.
Quindi stiamo entrando in un mondo in cui
questi prodotti saranno anche servizi,
servizi che possono essere dismessi
da un giorno all'altro,
alle mie spalle avete la foto di un hub
domotico, si chiama Revolve,
e i ragazzi che hanno inventato
Revolve hanno avuto la fortuna
di essere comprati
a un certo punto da Google,
in uno di questi sprazzi
di acquisto di startup,
e Google, la prima cosa che ha fatto,
visto che questo prodotto era competitor
con un altro prodotto di Google,
è stato dismesso.
E quindi tutti gli utenti che avevano
comprato questo prodotto,
si sono visti staccare un servizio,
ma loro non avevano comprato il servizio,
avevano comprato il prodotto.
Quindi c'è da chiarire questo rapporto,
che però, purtroppo, non riguarda soltanto
la casa di quel piccolo segmento
di popolazione
che in America ha comprato
uno hub domotico,
credo che in questa stanza
nessuno abbia uno hub domotico in casa,
io comunque non ce l'ho.
Questo sta avvenendo anche
nel mondo dell'agricoltura:
ci sono trattori che si spengono se
gli agricoltori non hanno pagato
la rata del mutuo, oggi,
nel 2016, in Europa.
Questo sta avvenendo,
non ancora in Europa,
però sta avvenendo anche
nel mondo delle auto.
Quindi lo stesso discorso dei trattori
può funzionare anche nel mondo automotive.
Questo è l'ambito in cui lavoro io,
nell'ambito degli oggetti connessi,
per lo più oggetti autocostruiti,
e questa è una fonte CISCO,
un'analisi che ha fatto
un colosso del web,
che diceva -
questa è una informazione del 2011 -
che nel 2020 avremo più o meno
sette, otto dispositivi connessi addosso.
La rettifica fatta nel 2015 era che
probabilmente l'infrastruttura web,
per come è stato costruito il web
fino ad adesso,
non riuscirà a gestirli,
sette o otto dispositivi connessi
per un totale di 50 miliardi
di dispositivi connessi
tra case, fabbriche,
e noi che camminiamo,
andiamo in giro, corriamo
e abbiamo il braccialetto
che dice
quanti passi abbiamo fatto.
E quindi, in questo white paper del 2015
che volevo portare alla vostra attenzione,
CISCO ha utilizzato per la prima volta
un termine che mi ha colpito molto,
fog computing o fogging, quindi
in contrapposizione alla nuvola, al cloud
c'è questo concetto della nebbia,
che è locale, bassa,
io e te ci parliamo,
ma da fuori non ci vedono,
io e te ci vediamo,
ma da fuori non ci vedono.
L'idea è quella di contenere a livello
computazionale, di potenza di calcolo,
di mantenere il locale.
Io mi immagino sempre
il discorso di una casa,
o di una fabbrica,
o di una fattoria,
tutta una serie di servizi
che contribuiscono al bene collettivo,
in un'ottica locale,
senza la necessità
che la app, che ti permette
di accendere la luce,
faccia una chiamata
a un server a San Francisco;
il server ripassa poi il dato sott'acqua,
arriva a casa mia e si accende la luce.
Ovviamente non era grazie a CISCO,
ma in generale un sacco di persone
hanno sviluppato negli ultimi anni
prodotti, dispositivi
che vanno in questa direzione,
per esempio questa applicazione,
che è stata utilizzata
in diversi eventi catastrofici e viene
utilizzata in diverse manifestazioni,
permette la comunicazione, le chat
in assenza di Internet.
Nel mio piccolo, in Italia,
noi abbiamo promosso, insieme ad Arduino,
un progetto di casa domotica che rispetta
questo tipo di concetti, di privacy,
di analisi e gestione di quello
che possono fare questi dispositivi:
il progetto Casa Jasmina.
E a livello di agricoltura abbiamo fatto,
in quest'ultimo anno, degli interventi
con degli agricoltori per traslare
questo discorso dalla casa a una fattoria
che è connessa in maniera locale.
Quindi vi lascio
con un pensiero positivo, non paranoico,
a quello che è Internet oggi,
e vi consiglio
di fare molto spesso dei backup.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)